Absolutely
huge, huge
news, a huge development,
as Jake said, a pickup
in Pennsylvania,
but also a kind of
moral victory
for Democrats
on a national level
because this was
where they went.
I mean,
President Biden basically
was there so much.
There you go.
Look at how excited
the people in Fetterman
headquarters are right now
as they not only
understand that they
that their candidate
won against
some pretty big odds,
but they're enjoying
seeing it
being projected on CNN.
And, you know,
one thing
I really cannot
get out of my head,
just going back to earlier
in the night
when we saw those excerpts
coming out of Pennsylvania
that basically said that voters
had made Letterman's health
as an issue a wash.
And then on the question
of has always lived
long enough in the state
to represent it effectively.
55% said no to me that was,
I think, probably
the first sign
that we had tonight
that something was going
to be happening
in Pennsylvania.
Republicans
thought this race was over
after that debate.
They thought that it had
disqualified Fetterman.
And the voters tonight
said something
totally different.
They were wrong.
I think, Abby,
this was a personal judgment
and yes, obviously,
John Fetterman had a stroke
and he still shows
the effects of it.
But voters were saying,
we trust this guy.
We think that he's there
for us.
And they just didn't feel
that about them at all.
They thought he,
you know,
was a guy who came in
to try to pick up a seat
across the state line.
And that he wasn't
there for them.
I think it was a
personal endorsement
of their faith and Fetterman
and really kind of a personal
rejection of none at all.
I should also say
what they're
seeing in Fetterman
headquarters is a delay of CNN,
which is why
you're seeing us kind of twice.
We are expecting
John Fetterman
to come out soon.
We talked earlier in the night
about how this
has been a race of two
very strong,
very distinct personalities.
And it was
certainly a national race,
but also about these two men
like you were both
talking about.
I think we also need to note
that this
this is very much a proxy
battle
and has been between Joe Biden
and Donald Trump.
And on this one.
Joe Biden won.
Yes, he was there
so many times.
And the only reason Mehmet
Oz is
and was the nominee
for the Republicans
is because of Donald Trump.
I mean, Joe
Biden was is a native
son of Pennsylvania
and really leaned
that into that really hard.
But what made this impossible,
frankly, for
Mehmet Oz at the end
was that here he is.
He's coming out on the front
and finish about
what made it impossible
for Fetterman
or for Oz
was that he was trying to sell
two different messages
appearing with Obama
while also.
Let's listen in. Him
Our
yeah.
I
yeah, I
I'm I'm
not really sure
really what to say right now.
My goodness.
Yeah,
I am
yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, me, too.
So I am I'm so humbled.
Thank you so much. Really.
Thank you.
Like it's what is it?
It's like one 30 in the morning
and you're still here
hanging in
we long
we launched this campaign
almost two years ago,
and we had our slogan.
It's on
every one of those signs
right now.
Every county, every vote,
every county, every vote.
And that's exactly
what happened.
We jammed them up
we held the line
I never expected
that we were going
to turn these
red counties blue,
but we did what
we needed to do,
and we had that conversation
across every one
of those counties
and tonight, that's why
I'll be the next U.S.
senator from Pennsylvania.
Thanks to all of you.
All of you.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
You know,
they made this great
for right now.
And
I just I want to I,
I want to thank,
of course,
all of all these supporters
all across
Pennsylvania, all in this room,
all across the nation,
everyone that
chipped in ten bucks
to help us get here.
Thank you.
And
I'm
yeah.
And and also, I want to
I also really want to thank my
my family
yeah.
My my mother,
my brother call Susan,
my brother Greg.
We're seeing
where she is
that was dissolved.
Everyone's hair.
Yeah. Chisel.
Yeah,
Who?
Six months ago,
she saved my life. Yeah.
What?
Walking out of a Sheetz
bathroom, she recognized
what was happening.
And also in my and my children.
Carl Grace.
August.
August,
and
so.
So, everyone, and thank you.
And I also want to
I also want to thank my
my team as well.
This team,
so many names like, you know,
Brandon, my campaign manager,
Rebecca,
Bobby, Joe,
Jamie, Jason, everybody,
all my team,
you know, so many,
so many
that made that part of it.
You know, I and I also
thank all
of the supporters also
I'm just so proud of the race
that we ran.
And, you know,
this campaign has always been
about fighting for everyone
who's ever
been got knocked down
that ever got back up
this race
is for the future
of every community all
across Pennsylvania.
For for every small town
or person
that ever felt left behind,
for every job
that was ever been lost.
For every factor
that was ever closed,
for every person
that works hard
but never going to
ever get ahead
I'm proud of what we ran on.
Protecting a woman's
right to choose
raising our minimum wage
and fighting
the union way of life.
Health care
is a fundamental human right.
It saved my life
and it should
all be there for you
when you ever need it.
Standing up
to corporate greed
making more things
right here in America
and right here in Pennsylvania.
And standing up
for our democracy
20 years ago,
I came to Braddock
to start a good program,
and I'm listening
to John Fetterman
of giving his victory speech
in Pennsylvania,
a remarkable turn of events
and a very closely
watched and vitally,
obviously important race
to Democrats
for in this election
David Urban,
I got to go to you,
Pennsylvania.
So, listen, it's
incredibly hard
for me to watch.
Obviously, this is
and this is to Pat Toomey seat.
Before that,
it was my former boss's
seat, Arlen Specter,
who held it
so, so proudly
for so many years.
And it's it's a big loss
for Pennsylvanians,
for Republicans
in Pennsylvania.
Listen,
I hope I wish John Fetterman
the best.
He won tonight.
He's got to do a great job
for all Pennsylvanians,
all 12 million.
Congratulations and good luck.
We need
we need him to do the best job.
But look, it's
a big blow for Republicans
and Republicanism
in the state of Pennsylvania.
And this is a loss
which I think is going
to reverberate across
the United States.
And it was hand-picked
by the hand-picked
by Donald Trump.
My good friend
Dave McCormick ran the race.
I supported Dr.
Oz's opponent
in this race, who I think
would have been
a far
stronger
candidate in this race.
And we're probably up there
giving a speech tonight
instead of John Fetterman.
And so
a lot of people
are going to ask
questions about
how can you lay this loss
at the feet of the president
the former president?
People are going to ask that
come in tomorrow
and the day after the day
after Pennsylvania.
And what Governor
I said, Governor,
you lost a governor's mansion
and a Senate race
in Pennsylvania tonight.
And and I know Republicans
across the commonwealth are
pretty upset right now.